françois et françois que se passe-t-il
je crois qu'il se passe quelque chose de
grave que dis tu non mais je ne veux pas
t'inquiéter 1
casimir c'est en toute aisance du
m'inquiète non mais dis moi est ce que
tu as un plan de lille une roche et
batterie attends je crois que julie en
inde en sont qu' on cherche cherche mais
tient justement le voilà tiens casimir
merci très bien donc il ya bien le
sentier des fraises
il allie des biches et le chemin du
petit bois qui signera pas quand même
passé en revue tous les chemins et les
sentiers qui les laisse moi terminer
pour la route des casimir us le sentir
et lapins la plage des tortues bon ça va
je suis rassuré cela va beaucoup mieux à
la fin on vieillit bien
il ya collé le grand chef indien que je
viens de voir n'est pas sur le sentier
de la guerre puisqu'il n'existe pas de
sentier de la guerre mon pauvre casimir
je crois que j'ai besoin d'une bonne
compresses d'eau froide sur la tête pour
te remettre les idées en place parce que
premièrement être sur le sentier de la
guerre signifait pour les indiens partir
à la guerre et deuxième non il n'y a
jamais eu de chaîne
casimir aubin écoute moi quand je te
parle je regarde mon rêve rick hughes
bonjour monsieur hu est revenue aux amis
oui bien c'est ruiner nos amis aussi -
venus re sur ce gros ventre sans escale
qu'est ce que ça veut dire gros ventre
son scalp de revendre son scalp son
scalp ça veut dire son cheveu je crois
qu'il s'agit de toi quoi moi groovant
concentre toi indien toujours donné nom
facile pour reconnaître hommes j'ai rien
compris
eh bien il veut expliquer que chez les
indiens il aime bien donner des noms qui
permettent de reconnaître du premier
coup d'oeil le visage ou la silhouette
de quelqu'un il aurait pu trouver
quelque chose de plus aimable mois
grosse et ciu regard intelligent un bon
eh bien moi j'aurais plutôt pensé tête
de veau ou high de poisson frit
heureusement
au ventre sans escale pour être venu
alex prugh de paix pour t'inviter à la
grande fête donnée par les chefs de
tribu indien mavic et moi mais mais
pourquoi moi savoie gros ventre sans
scalpel grand chef de casimir us mais
c'est bien vrai ça
casimir tu n'es pas inquiet nous y
allons qu'est ce que ça peut faire tu
vas voir
attends moi au ventre sans escale faire
vite bateau partir très bientôt
et voilà et regard intelligent avoir
fait un long voyage hors m'en parlez pas
d'abord lautoka ensuite le train pour
finir le bateau tape récent de sentir le
cambouis en un mot ce fut épouvantable
et tout ça pour se battre et et de deux
têtes de voix au nom river l'arrivée
vous comprendre regard intelligent
furieux de ne plus savoir ce qu'il dure
et bien attendez moi un instant je
reviens tout de suite ce chef pour uche
m'a l'air bien étrange les enfants venez
venez vite
les enfants j'ai besoin de votre aide je
voudrais savoir si le chef regard
intelligent est un véritable indien
alors je lui posais un certain nombre de
questions et vous me direz si ses
réponses sont vraies d'accord et vous si
chez vous chef regard intelligent
le luc
je voudrais savoir quelle est votre
métier ouah grand chef sioux oui oui
bien sûr mais je pense que comme tous
les autres indiens d'aujourd'hui
vivaient dans des maisons vous roulez en
automobile vous porter des cravates de
temps en temps pas de tout regard autant
vivre comme faisant feutre ah bon et
dans quoi vivez-vous d'un igloo les
enfants vous êtes d'accord
donc quoi les aliens dans une tente qui
s'appelle un tipi très bien quand vous
allez à la chasse quel est l'animal que
vous chassez le t bond non les visant
les bisons d'accord mais c est pour
faire la paix que le fut mais vous le
sud or
mais la paix très bien et chef le regard
intelligent
quelles sont les tâches que vous lancez
les colocs tv zac les rejets viennent
s'appelle des tomawak merci regard
intelligent c'est tout merci les enfants
d'aller jouer
ce chef regard intelligent c'est
vraiment beaucoup trop d'erreurs pour
être un véritable chef indien
c'est quelque chose de logique
[Musique]
grand chef casemiro cette rentrée à
partir pour le grand conseil
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous partir tout de suite bon d'accord
allons-y qu'est ce qu'on écoute des
personnes tu vas nous faire rater le
bateau là ça vaudrait peut-être mieux
je crois que regard intelligent n'est
pas un véritable pour leur écoute alors
c'est toujours pareil
dès qu'on a fait quelque chose d'amusant
tu veux m'en empêcher ce n'est pas du
tout que je sais c'est parce que tu es
jaloux parce que je suis un grand chef
moi même ce numéro passé si si si payant
est pas tout à casimir us alors laissez
moi partir au revoir bonne chose casimir
duchess je suis prêt regard intelligent
bravo bravo dépêchez vous c'est un grand
artiste mais ça y est j'ai trouvé casino
c'est albert travelling est sérieux ou
celui qui veut emmener pour te montrer à
tout le monde dans une cage comme un
horrible et méchant et oui oui oui c'est
moi c'est bien moi j'espérais pouvoir
vous emmener mes amis avec mila l'auteur
qui les paient casimir pourquoi dis-tu
sait encore comment veux tu que j'arrive
à le scalp et il a des cheveux tellement
court avec mes quatre gros doigts je
n'aurais pas réussi à les attraper pour
le scalp et au casimir
à